Hey, good morning, everybody, and thank you for attending on
a Saturday morning. Great session to kick
off
Saturday morning at AACR.
We also thank you for everyone who's joining in online.
So I'm pleased to chair this session.
My name's Gideon Blumenthal, and we have a great
panel and session of speakers today.
We're going to be talking about dose optimization in early phase oncology
trials, implementing the vision of FDA's
Project Optimus.
So the way this educational session will go
is, we'll have four speakers,
and each will give approximately a 15-minute talk,
and then we'll have
20 minutes, half an hour at the end for an open
Q&A session. So we'll hold all the questions till the end of the
session. We do have this QR code.
So I believe if you want to
download the QR, you can ask questions to our
online forum via the QR code. So we'll
leave this up to give you the opportunity
to scan the QR code.
And while we're doing that, our first speaker,
I'm honored to introduce Dr. Murat Shaw,
one of the architects of Project Optimus from the
US Food and Drug Administration. Thank you.
Good morning, everyone. My name is Murat Shaw, and I am a medical
oncologist at FDA. I'm also the clinical lead for FDA
Oncology Center of Excellence's-
Little closer.
Oh, yes. Gideon is a bit taller than me, yes.
Should've mentioned that.
How's that?
Better.
Okay, thanks. So I'll start again. My name is Murat Shaw.
I'm a medical oncologist at FDA and also the clinical
lead for FDA Oncology Center of Excellence's Project Optimus.
Project Optimus is our effort to improve how dosages are selected
for cancer drugs, and I'd like to thank the conference and session
organizers for inviting me here today to give this five-year update
on implementation of Project Optimus.
First, these are my disclosures, and I just want to highlight that my slides
represent a rapidly evolving area in regulatory
science.
So in my short talk today, I will provide a little bit of
review as to why Project Optimus came about.
I'll discuss a little bit of how FDA Oncology has implemented
Project Optimus. I will then highlight what has changed
over the past five years, and some
recent case examples of dosage optimization.
And then finally, I'll conclude and turn the session over to the other speakers.
So first, a bit of review as to why Project Optimus came to
be. There are a few main threads that came together.
The first being that historically, the way that we have chosen the dosages for
cancer drugs is based on something called the maximum tolerated dose,
which was developed for cytotoxic chemotherapies.
Small numbers of patients would be exposed to escalating doses,
evaluated for dose-limiting toxicities, and then eventually the
MTT, or maximum tolerated dose, would be reached.
Only serious or life-threatening toxicities were considered dose-limiting, and the
observation period for these toxicities was quite short.
Of course, most cancer drugs in development today are targeted drugs or
biologics, and they have different properties from cytotoxic
chemotherapies. One being that unlike cytotoxic
chemotherapies, which
may be given for a fixed number of cycles, some of these newer drugs, because
of their efficacy, may be given for many months or even years.
And so low-grade tolerability, things like Grade 1 or 2 diarrhea,
become very, very important to the overall tolerability of the drug.
Additionally, some of these newer drugs have different scientific properties from
cytotoxic chemotherapies, such that a lower dose may have
similar efficacy but better safety to a higher
dose.
Second, many stakeholders, including patients, patient
advocates, oncologists, professional societies,
regulators, and industry, all recognize that the lack
of dosage optimization for cancer drugs was a huge problem with negative
consequences on patient lives. And so this slide
highlights that across stakeholders, there were growing calls to action
for dosage optimization for cancer drugs.
And then finally, FDA also became concerned because in some
cases, lack of dosage optimization might have severe
negative consequences, including potential detrimental impacts on overall
survival. So PI3K kinase inhibitors were approved
for hematologic malignancies on the basis of overall response rate
or progression-free survival data.
And later, in large randomized trials for several of these products, potential
detrimental impacts on overall survival were observed.
When FDA looked at these cases, we realized that one of the contributors
to these potential detrimental impacts on overall survival could be a
lack of dosage optimization early in development, leading to problems with
safety later on at the doses that were selected to be carried forward.
So for all of those reasons, FDA Oncology Center of Excellence established
Project Optimus with the mission of reforming the dosing paradigm in oncology
drug development. And who we are is a multidisciplinary team of
scientists across FDA with expertise in different aspects of
dosage optimization, and there's more information on our
website.The ways in which we implemented
Project Optimus and dosage optimization is through guidance documents,
the oncology dosing toolkit, I'll go into more detail on both of these things on
later slides, and also through milestone meetings and other
formal interactions with drug sponsors.
So now, before even the first in-human clinical trial is
initiated, FDA is providing advice on dosage optimization,
and drug sponsors are seeking our input on dosage optimization throughout
meetings
prior to drug approval, and our advice can become more specific and more tailored
as more information is available on a product.
One thing to highlight, Type D meetings is a new meeting type that was offered
under PDUFA VII. It's more focused.
It has a slightly faster turnaround time, and we've noticed in particular that
drug sponsors are using this type of interaction to seek
feedback on dosage optimization.
So next, I'll go through a little bit of the key principles in the dosage
optimization guidance, which was developed specifically for oncology
drugs.
So ideally, dosage optimization should occur prior to drug
approval, and rather than focusing on one aspect like
safety or DLTs, it's very important to use the totality
of information available to guide dosage selection, which
includes PK/PD data, safety, early
efficacy, and especially dose and exposure response relationship
information.
I'll go into more detail on the next slide and highlight how randomized comparisons
can support identification of optimized dosages.
As I alluded to earlier, safety assessments should include
things like low-grade symptomatic toxicities, which can be very problematic,
affecting tolerability. And then finally, there is
no one size fits all. It's important that the dosage optimization strategy
be appropriate for the specific drug and the specific disease in
which the drug is being developed, and FDA can provide advice.
So this slide highlights pictorially some of the key aspects of the
dosage optimization guidance, and this is what an updated dosage
selection strategy could look like, implementing the principles of dosage
optimization. So during dose escalation, rather than have the
goal of identifying the maximum tolerated dose, instead, the goal could
be to identify a potentially therapeutic dose range.
After this, several dosages within that dose range could be
compared in a randomized assessment for more dosage
optimization. I want to emphasize that the point of this randomized
comparison is not to prove that one dose is statistically superior
to another. Instead, the purpose of randomization is really to
try and have some balance in the baseline characteristics of the patients being
evaluated to have easier interpretation of the dose response
relationships. After that, rather than the maximum tolerated
dose, an optimized dosage could be evaluated in a randomized controlled
trial with a standard of care control arm.
And if that optimized dosage succeeds, then that would become the recommended
dosage in FDA labeling.
The arrows on the slide illustrate that dosage optimization does not need to
occur as a standalone, separate clinical trial.
This is something that, depending on the development program, could be part of a
Phase 1 dosage expansion cohort.
Instead, also, a randomized trial with a standard of care control
arm could have multiple dosage arms.
And then finally, I'll just briefly mention that one other resource that FDA has
available is the Oncology Dosing Toolkit, which was developed to help drug
sponsors and other stakeholders
make informed decisions about which dosages to evaluate in clinical development.
This dosing toolkit highlights key areas that can form the
totality of data that you can use to decide which dosages
to evaluate at different times in clinical development.
So now I want to turn our attention to what has happened,
what has changed over the past five years.
So since initiation of Project Optimus, for most products, FDA is
providing dosage optimization advice before the first in-human trial
is initiated, as early as pre-IND meetings or during an initial
30-day IND submission. In many programs, we've noticed
that drug sponsors are incorporating backfill, additional dosage cohorts, and
randomized dosage evaluations in their pre-approval
development program. And on the next slide, I will highlight some case
examples that illustrate that dosage optimization is feasible even for
expedited development programs and how it can improve safety for
patients.
So this slide highlights some recent examples of dosage optimization in
advanced lung cancer. These are all drugs that received their
initial approval for the lung cancer indication shown between
2022 and 2025, so over the time period
under which Project Optimus has occurred.
I'll highlight some things on this slide as you're taking a look.
So the name of the drug is in the left column, and this
includes an antibody drug conjugate, a bispecific T cell
engager, and small molecule kinase inhibitors, indicating that
dosage optimization is feasible for different classes of product.
In the center column, these products all incorporated a randomized
assessment of multiple dosages as part of their pre-approval
development program, and you can see the dosages that were evaluated in that
center column. The column to the right of that,
yes, your right and my right. The column to the right of that shows the dose that
became the recommended dosage in FDA labeling.
And for all four of these cases, actually, the lower dose or the dosing
regimen with the lower doses became the recommended dosage.
So really illustrating that without this dosage optimization,
maybe the higher dose would have been the one that if the program had
succeeded, maybe that would have been the one that would have been the one patients
were exposed to. And really by doing this dosage optimization, the benefit risk
to patients improved for these drugs.
And also, patients are able to receive a safer dose at
theat the time of drug approval. And
then finally, all of these products received accelerated approval for
their initial approval for the lung cancer indication shown, highlighting
that even for these programs on rapid development timelines, dosage
optimization was feasible. And I'm happy to expand
more on the relationship between dosage optimization and
accelerated approval during the Q&A or discussion.
So of course, even with these initial successes, there are continued challenges for
dosage optimization, and these include making sure that the dosage
optimization approach is appropriate to the specific drug and
program rather than something that's a one size
fits all.
Some of the other continued challenges are for randomized evaluations determining
the size of the dosage
cohorts, and then how to best select the dosages to compare to
one another. Best approaches for combination therapies is another
important area of dosage optimization that needs some more attention.
And then finally, how to assess tolerability in early
clinical development in more patient-centric ways and beyond
clinician-assessed reports of safety.
Several of my colleagues on the panel will talk a little bit more, I think, about
all of these points on the bottom of the slide in their talks.
And finally, to conclude, since initiation of Project
Optimus, FDA is providing advice on dosage optimization early in
clinical development, and drug sponsors are conducting dosage
optimization as part of their pre-market development.
The case examples I shared showed that dosage optimization is feasible
even for programs with rapid development timelines and improved
safety and overall benefit risk for patients.
And then finally, I want to highlight that the success
of dosage optimization and the adoption across
oncology is really a testament to all stakeholders,
patients, patient advocates, oncologists, professional societies,
industry regulators, all have understood the importance
of this, and this is really why I think this has been so
successfully taken on over the past few years.
Of course, as my previous slide alluded to, there is still some
important areas where there could be improvement, areas of opportunity for
improvement in dosage optimization.
And
finally, I'd like to thank all of my colleagues at FDA, especially Dr.
Atiq Rahman, my co-lead for Project Optimus, all members of the
FDA team,
and all of you for your attention today, and I'm looking forward to the discussion.
Thank you, Dr. Shaw.
Next we have Dr. Alexia Iossifidis from
Memorial Sloan Kettering Cancer Center, talking about
utilizing randomization backfill and expansion cohorts to gain greater
understanding in phase one trials.
Thank you so much. Good morning, everyone.
Thank you for the invitation, and thank you for attending on a
Saturday morning.
These are my disclosures. I would like to start with acknowledging my colleagues at
Memorial, at the FDA, in industry, and of course, at
University College of London and Sorbonne, where I have done
research in methodological advancements in phase one.
This is a paper we published last year with FDA
ACR,
summarizing our recommendations after the public workshop.
So I will summarize what we have done at my institution, Memorial Sloan
Kettering, the last 20 years, and how we got here, and how we're
working towards the future. So we started by evaluating
several designs and recommending which one to use.
We implemented it in an institutional database so that Bayesian
adaptive model-based design can happen behind the scenes, and we
get predictions so that the patient can get assigned to the
right dose at the time of patient registration.
We evaluated different endpoints with respect to causation and lower
grade toxicities, how predictive they are for
predicting dose limiting toxicities.
And we partnered with CTEP and NCI to revise or revisit
eligibility criteria with respect to brain mets and age.
We developed a nomogram predicting the risk for developing
toxicity before the patient is treated, to assess if
a patient is a good candidate for phase one trials.
And we were part of the GENIE project looking at AKT
breast cancer
patients with mutations establishing synthetic
controls. The last few years, of course, we're working
in biomarker and histology specific subgroups, basket and
expansion cohorts, randomized phase one trials,
and focusing on the FDA Optimus and of course, on
portfolio selection and model calibration.
We all know in the room when we start thinking about a trial, we're thinking
whom to treat and when to treat and what is the best treatment.
So we're looking for a successful endpoint,
but we have to adhere to ethical constraints, and in this case,
it's not to treat patients at low dose or high dose or outside of
the therapeutic window. And what makes our job even
harder is that we're trying to address a research
scientific question in a protocol while at the same time
providing the best treatment care.
And in this case, it's not treating patients at
subtherapeutic levels. You've heard from Dr.
Shaw, the left panel here is the chemotherapy setting, more
is better, whereas the right panel here is less is more.
So the idea of the backfill or dose expansions is to go backwards
and enroll more patients at lower levels and address the
scientific question, are they similar or
similar in terms of efficacy?So the randomized expansion
cohort is different than the backfill in that we go up the
levels, we find the MTD or the vicinity of the
MTD, and then we select two levels to take forward to the
expansion cohort. Whereas the backfill cohorts happen
simultaneously before we reach the MTD, as we go up the
dose escalation, we go backwards and expand
or backfill lower levels so that we can augment the
data and get more information at the lower levels.
So the left-hand side here shows the simple dose escalation setting,
whereas the middle is the dose escalation with expansion, trying
to address efficacy. And the right panel here is the dose
expansion or backfill or what we call amplification,
adding more data to address whether the drug works uniformly
in different disease cohorts or subgroups, address the
question of safety, efficacy, identify the right population,
treatment, or schedule, and which drugs to
eliminate. So we are looking for futility analysis in
addition, so that we can move the
portfolio selection forward. So of course, the question
is how many patients and how many dose levels?
Depending on the patient heterogeneity, these will determine the sample size
with respect to how many diseases, how many dose levels, and
whether we're looking for efficacy.
Subgroups can be small in the sense of 20 patients per
subgroup, but if we have many subgroups with respect to
schedule and dose and disease, it can add up quickly.
So how do we determine the sample size?
The answer is on the number of questions being addressed and the
hierarchy of the questions, the primary questions versus the secondary and
exploratory. We know that the majority of Phase 1 trials do not
lead to a successful Phase 3 trial,
so we have to collect data to understand why the drug
failed, and is there possibly another area where we
can explore it further. So we need to
eliminate systematic biases and get rigorous data.
And of course, one can ask, why do we need randomization since eligibility
criteria is going to balance these
patient characteristics at baseline, such as comorbidities, prior treatment,
advanced disease? Randomization is here to balance the
unknown and unmeasured factors, and this is why
we still have risk factors that are unknown or not
quantified at baseline. The pros are that we have a
concurrent comparison. Here is a different dose.
We have uniform evaluation criteria, both with respect to risk
factors that are known and unknown, they're balanced, and can be
used to evaluate additional questions such as biomarkers, PK, and PD.
The question, though, is that do we have the resources to
have a randomization in real time, and is it going to
affect accrual and duration? It does not increase the sample size
necessarily because these are not powered
cohorts to test a hypothesized difference.
So I will show you how we can use probabilistic statements
or estimates from
model-based Phase 1 designs, and at the end, the savings might
seem small in the
range of three to six patients. But these are important savings
because we can allocate them in another cohort, in another
PK/PD cohort, or move it elsewhere.
These stopping rules have been around for a while in the statistical
literature, but in a recent paper, we compared different
rules based on posterior probability from a model, tree-based
evaluation where you predict all possible outcomes,
or ad hoc rules such as, do you see six patients being
enrolled at the same dose? So how they look, we have the patients
on the left coming in as they get accrued, and they are treated at different
levels. And then on the right is this posterior probability.
At the beginning, it's pretty flat, indicating any dose level can be the
MTD. As we enroll more patients, you see these histograms
being shifted.
If we have no DLTs, you see it's concentrated around 200
milligrams, and the two other co-MTDs are the adjacent
levels, 100 and 400. And as we move on and we
have no DLTs, you can see that MTD is
likely going to be level 200 and the co-MTD will be 400.
And we decide when we have sufficient data to stop.
In terms of portfolio selection and regulatory approval, we know
that many industry sponsors, but also at
Memorial, we have an early drug development service
that has led programs that paved the way for the tumor-agnostic regulatory
approval of several drugs. These are usually from basket trials or
dose expansion cohorts. They're rare
cancers. There is an unmet need. There is no available treatment.
And in this setting, it is acceptable to have an accelerated
regulatory approval. But we all know that not
all drugs are a success story, right?
So there is no boilerplate design that can address all the clinical
objectives. The research questions and the hierarchy, and the
importance will determine the optimal design.
Each trial, as you heard before, has unique elements based on the
preclinical data, clinical, and emerging data from
other trials. It could be a similar formulation of a drug
or some other indication. The goal is to
maximize information, and that's why randomization will
spread... the patients across those levels in a balanced
way and in a structured way so that we can interpret the data at the
end in a meaningful way. We also published a paper
in "Rare Cancers" because it has specific
considerations, and we gave examples of where a
post-marketing trial was necessary so that
we can optimize the dose. And that, of course, is not
cost-effective or also possibly ethical.
So we are trying to do dose optimization early, as you heard from my colleague.
The summary from this talk is that randomization is an established
tool. We know a lot about it. It's a tool that we can
use. Adaptive model-based designs provide solutions to the
current clinical challenges, and these probabilistic estimates can
get us to the correct answer.
Still, though, small dose escalation phase one designs, in the simplest
way that I showed from the table, have an important role, and it
depends on the clinical setting.
My colleague, Matthew Klertan, published this paper in JCO, I
think two years ago, summarizing why do we need so many
designs, and how can we group the 20 different designs
into three classes, and what are the similarities and differences
or pros and cons? And this is an easy-to-read
paper.
I wouldn't be here in 2026 without mentioning artificial
intelligence. I would welcome questions and feedback at the end.
And of course, we are all here to work together to find the
answers. We have different stakeholders, as we know, and
the goal is to use AI to help us, right?
How can we reduce cost and time? How can we reduce
patients while still including multiple
geographical sites and maintaining rigor?
So I think we can all agree that we're going to see fast
development
of AI and applications helping us reduce the
regulatory monitoring, reporting, site initiation,
activation, budgeting, enrollment, screening and matching,
finding the patients, and the consent process.
So maybe these are all under the umbrella of administrative tasks.
The question we are here or in the future is, can
AI help us leverage data and models to address the scientific question?
There is a lot out there, and there is also a lot of confusion because there is
no
consensus on the definitions. A digital twin is
an in silico framework that replicates a biological cell,
subsystem, organ, or a whole organism with a transparent,
predictive model of the relevant causal mechanism and response to
intervention. It's simulation-based.
And a virtual twin is basically a digital twin that now
changes over time, is not simulated one time.
This figure, I found it very interesting.
It includes organs and tissues, environmental and lifestyle,
genetic and regulatory data, cellular and historical data.
These are all the X variables, multidimensional things we know at
baseline. Baseline is defined different for different settings,
right? Is the time of diagnosis, time of surgery, time of
interval debulking, time when they came to our
institution. So the idea is that we are putting all these X
variables, and then if we have the Y, the outcome, which here is
response or
toxicity, then we can have a prediction of how
is this digital twin going to work in
a clinical trial. So in summary, this is a
framework where we are using predictions from a model or AI as
data.
And the publications out there that claim that this will
solve a lot of problems, although I'm skeptical, is that
the simulation
patient digital twin will be monitored over time.
We will simulate the control or active
treatment circumstances, and then we're going to predict the
outcome. We're going to have real-world data, patient evaluation.
This is in a loop, and it goes back, and it gets updated.
And again, we're still using predictions as data.
But I will leave you with these thoughts that AI in drug development
versus AI in clinical research are two separate
concepts. I can see how AI is
going to help us find new drugs. We can use predictive modeling in
the preclinical setting and reduce trial failure.
I can see where it can help us find patients.
We can match patients or be more methodical
about our patient selection and inclusion criteria, but we are
far away from virtual trials. The risk and benefit is
unknown and needs to be studied extensively before it can be
used. Thank you.
Thanks very much. And next we have Dr.
Xing Li from Columbia University to talk
about ensuring tolerability by incorporating patient-reported
outcomes in dose-finding clinical trials. Thank you, Dr. Li.
Thank you so much for the invitation to speak here, and I'm glad to see so many of
you this early on a Saturday morning.
So I'm going to be shifting gears and addressing one of the comments that
Murat mentioned about how to incorporate patient information
to assess tolerability in the setting of
dose-finding clinical trials.
No financial disclosures, and I'm going to go over the general guideline
and the framework that we have been using in the past.
So generally, the idea has been that we select a DOT threshold, and that's
generally the oncology world has been about 25, 30% that
we consider to be acceptable level of toxicity for a drug.
And the concept has been that we assign a first cohort of patients
a specific dose that we think is going to be well-tolerated
Then we obtain outcomes from these patients, right? And then we wait.
What's going to happen? The outcomes that we have been using is DLT,
which is dose-limiting toxicity, which are defined based on the National
Cancer Institute Common Terminology Criteria of Adverse Event, the NCI
CTCAE. And we have been using the presence of a Grade 3 or
higher hematologic or Grade 3 or higher non-hematologic toxicity.
And these you can say that are based mainly on safety.
We don't want to see any events that are going to be alarming or life-threatening.
And based on these outcomes, we assign the next cohort of patients.
What we can do here is we can use different designs to decide how we're going to
assign the doses. We can assign doses based on the 3+3, which
that's all history already, hopefully.
We can use the continual reassessment method, the Bayesian optimal interval
designs. All of these are methods that will tell us how to treat the next cohort.
There are differences among them in the case that we're using data only on
the cohort that we have or data across those
levels.
And then we repeat this process until some stopping rule in terms of
sample size or other stopping criteria.
And at the end, we recommend what we think is the tolerable dose.
That in the past has been the maximum tolerated dose that we're
questioning right now. And the MTD has been defined as the
dose that satisfied that originally stated threshold.
The question that comes to mind now is does DLT as defined capture
tolerability, right? It doesn't include information on
those Grade 2 toxicity. So a patient that
experiences a very long, miserable Grade 2 toxicity
would not be considered a DLT, and that in itself could be not well
tolerated.
So how can we address that?
Going back to the FDA dose optimization guideline from 2024, there are a
few statements that mention that the dose that was recommended
may be unnecessarily high, poorly, or not adequately tolerated from the
patient perspective, and that can affect the patient's ability to remain on the
drug. At the same time, one suggestion has been to incorporate
patient-reported outcomes to see if we can enhance the tolerability in
those finding clinical trials, but not just those finding, but subsequent trials as
well.
So why PROs? So I have a little cartoon here to express
that. So when we collect the patient reported outcome, the patient may be
feeling not so great.
This face can say it all. However, when you go to the clinician and they
are writing down the CTCAE, the clinician may think that that's a mild
toxicity and not really a cause for concern, and they write down a
Grade 1 or Grade 2 toxicity.
That, of course, would not constitute a dose-limiting toxicity based on the
definition that we had.
There's a lot of work showing that understanding tolerability
should come directly from the patient, and the PRO is probably better
informed tolerability, right? The patient is speaking directly.
You're collecting the symptom information directly from the patient to say how
well they feel about the symptoms that they're experiencing.
And there's literature to suggest that there's underreporting of symptoms by
clinicians. So sometimes, especially in the phase one setting, it can be that
clinicians will prompt patients for toxicities that they're expecting,
and those are the ones that get captured and not necessarily other symptoms.
So how has been PRO used in the dose finding setting?
We know
there's been surveys, international stakeholders that say 100%
agree that PROs should be used to inform those escalation and those
decisions. And there's an increasing number of clinical trials using
collecting PROs. However, most of these trials don't include clear PRO
objectives of how the PRO is going to be used to inform the
decisions. And there's a lack of consistency on the instruments that are being
used, either a quality of life instrument sometimes, and sometimes they're
most based on symptoms, which they're different in nature.
So what are some considerations before I go into the methods that we can use for
PRO in the dose finding setting? What are general considerations that you should
have when you're including PRO?
Please make sure to use a validated instrument.
Make sure that it is an instrument that is assessing the patient-reported adverse
event, not necessarily quality of life.
So the instrument that has been used more in the phase one setting
is the PRO CTCAE. It is a companion instrument for the
CTCAE that is directly collecting patient-reported information
and focusing on the symptoms that are on the CTCAE.
And it uses a similar grading from
mild, moderate, severe, and Grade 4, which would be
life-threatening.
Evaluate the time commitment from patients to reduce missing data.
It can be quite extensive, especially when the PRO
instruments,
if you have any information about the toxicity of the drug, you could limit
it to the toxicities that you're expecting.
However, in some settings, you might have to ask about everything because you don't
know what the toxicities are going to be.
Include patient advocates to assess the time commitment from the
patients to know that it is doable, and
specify how tolerability will be defined based on these
PROs. We have the dose-limiting toxicities that we have been using from the
CTCAE. However, when we're coming to the PRO CTCAE, how do
we define tolerability? We're going to be having a laundry list of
toxicities and symptoms, and how do we define from there what is tolerable and
what is not? And this is where your patient advocate may really help
you. Also specify how PROs will be used
to inform the dose escalation and dose recommendation decisions.
And in context of what Mira presented, I'm focusing here more on the dose
escalation component,
that first part of the dose optimization framework,
to figure out which doses you should take on to the dose
randomization stage to ensure that they are
tolerable.So what are the approaches that we can use?
The first one, I'm going to go into more detail on each one of them, but the first
idea is to review the PRO that you collect and see how that informs
your CTCAE grading. So that's one approach.
The second approach is more to formally incorporate PRO data by
setting specific thresholds similar to what we do for the DLT
using the CTCAE. What level of
rate of toxicity would be acceptable in that
context? And we can include PRO data for dose
escalation decisions, plus dose estimation, or only
use PRO data at the end of the trial to ensure that the doses that
we take on can be well-tolerated in the dose optimization
stage.
So in the first context for the review of PRO to inform CTCAE grading,
you can see that the general framework is similar here.
The only thing I've added is this PRO CTCAE collection.
So at the same time that we collect the CTCAE data, we can collect
the PRO CTCAE directly from the patient at each of the visits in
which we collect the CTCAE. And that information, in the
logistical sense, can be shared with the clinician to see how that affects
the
grading of the clinician just by knowing what the patient themselves are
feeling. And that's one approach that we can do.
The advantage and disadvantages of that is that
the cons for that is that the PRO is incorporated directly.
Here, there's no sense of how the clinician, you have no
control of how the clinician will use that PRO information, and it can be
inconsistent going from clinician to clinician. Right?
So depending on the clinician, some clinicians may feel like that symptom
is not well-tolerated, my other clinicians might think, "Oh, it's not so bad."
So there might be some
subjectivity in that.
The advantage is that then we can use the standard designs that we have been using.
Right? There's plenty of designs that we currently use, and all of those designs
can be used to recommend the
dose.
The second concept is incorporating PRO formally by setting a threshold.
So what do I mean by that? So the DLT threshold that we have
for CTCAE is 25%. If we figure out how to
define tolerability from the patient perspective, we can set another
threshold for that. So we can say that, for example, here, I don't want to see
more than 35% of the patients saying that they have a severe
adverse event or severe symptom that they cannot tolerate.
In scenario one, assuming that we knew, this is hypothetical,
the probability of toxicity at each dose level, here I have five dose
levels, assuming that I knew what they were, and we have
the clinician here at 25% on dose level three.
And if the patient is also 35%, then it's not of concern. Right?
If I use my standard method, I would be recommending any
doses below
that would be well-tolerated. In scenario two, however,
based on the clinician threshold, it would be dose level four.
So this is where we have a concern, that if we use a threshold for
35% from the patient perspective, the patients would say that
anything
above a dose level two would not be well-tolerated from their perspective.
So it would be more a dose level two or lower that would be considered
tolerable.
So we developed a method that accounts for that, and it's called the
patient-reported outcome of the continual reassessment method, or the TIDE version,
which accounts for late onset toxicity.
So the framework is as follow. You select the threshold that you think for
the DLT, which can be your standard 25%, and at the same
time, you can select a threshold for the PRO, which can be
35%, 55%, whatever you think is
acceptable threshold. Of course, the higher the threshold, the less you're
using the PRO information. Right?
Because that's not going to come in very often.
Then you obtain data both from the PRO and the CTCAE
concurrently when you're conducting the trial.
And the concept is that you would estimate the doses based on the PRO
and the CTCAE independently, and using either the
CRM or the TIDE-CRM, and then at the assignment stage, you
would select the smaller of the two doses.
And by doing that, you're basically ensuring that it is tolerable both from the
patient perspective and the clinician original outcome.
And you repeat this process until you recommend the
recommendation dose. And by doing that, the dose that you're selecting
would satisfy both the DLT threshold from the patient perspective and the
clinician perspective.
There is a software already developed to run simulations for the PRO
CRM.
You can scan this. This is out of the University of Virginia by Dr.
Nolan Wages, and here you can specify the probability of toxicities that you
expect, the true probability of toxicities for the patient
perspective, and the targets that you're looking
for. We have also developed a web application
for conduct that will tell you based on the data that you've collected, what dose
should be assigned to the next patient.
And this is an application that we develop in our own group.
And you can see it has a data visualization component as well as
a dose
assignment component.
The PRO CRM has also been applied in practice in a phase one study
of radiation therapy. This is as an
example of how they chose the thresholds.
The clinician DLT, you can say that they use the traditional
definitions of grade three or higher.
For patient-related toxicity, they're actually using a grade four or higher
because they wanted to make sure that the subjectivity is taken into account.
And they're focusing only on GI and GU toxicity, given that the radiation
therapy is focused on that.
The tolerable dose, you can see here, it would be the minimum of the dose
that
satisfy the threshold of 20% from the clinician perspective, but the PRO
threshold was chosen to be much higher at 55%.
So they don't have to coincide, you can decide
on that component.Another way to do it is to
incorporate the PRO data only at the end. So that will save time.
So it is possible that you don't want to have the patient filling out PROs at every
visit, and you don't have concurrent PRO information.
So in this case, you might do it only at the end of cycle one or at the end
of
each cycle. And based on that information, you don't have to do it
here when you assign the doses, but you can use it at the end to
ensure that the dose that you're recommending for dose optimization will satisfy
both thresholds. So this is an approach that you can use for that.
And from simulation studies, this is a little more conservative compared to
actually using it at each stage.
So in conclusion, the FDA Project Optimus suggests inclusion of
PRO in dose finding to ensure patient tolerability.
And
we have seen that already. The PRO
CTCAE has been used for collection of symptoms in dose-finding clinical
trials. There has been a few studies showing this feasibility in doing so.
So when you're doing your dose-finding clinical trials, just don't collect PRO for
the sake of collecting it. Think about how you're going to be using it to inform
tolerability, right? Because otherwise, the information will just rest there, and
you might be very ad hoc at the end when you incorporate that information.
Clearly define tolerability from the patient perspective and use your patient,
communicate with your patient advocates to understand exactly what it means
in terms of symptoms of what
is tolerable and what is not. I wanted to point out that I have
shown some methods and I have shown some web applications that exist.
If you are interested in formally including PROs in terms
of
specifying a threshold both for the dose assignment and estimation,
and there have been more work on extension of using those finding designs that
include PRO, such as using a utility
approach, for example.
And here are the references in case you're interested in any of this work.
Thank you very much.
Great job.
Great. Thank you so much. So, our last talk before we go
into Q&A.
I'm going to provide the industry perspective, the
Project Optimus at five years on finding a more optimal dose.
So just to give a little bit of my background, I'm fairly new to Pfizer.
Before that, I spent six years at Merck.
Before that, I was over a decade at the US Food and Drug Administration.
So I can kind of straddle
some of the divide
between industry and the regulatory space.
So
in general, although objectives largely overlap,
the sponsor and the regulator's perspectives and pressures may
slightly differ.
From an oncology sponsor perspective, the goal
is to develop a differentiated therapy with unambiguous
advantage to benefit patients in terms of safety and efficacy.
There are a lot of pressures. As you can see at this meeting,
there's
intense
competition. There's time pressures, cost.
There's a rapidly changing standard of care.
There are competing priorities within the
company. From a regulatory perspective,
the goal is to approve a therapy that is safe and effective with a
favorable benefit risk profile at the lowest dose
possible.
Pressures include criticisms of being too
fast or too slow,
too lax or too conservative, too rigorous. Dr.
Pazdur is in the audience. He used to say, "If you're not
upsetting someone on a day-to-day basis at your job, you're probably
not doing your job right." So that's kind of the pressures that
the regulator faces.
So we heard a lot about Project Optimus.
Since 2021,
there's been a renewed focus on dose optimization in the
pre-marketing setting. For those of you who have worked in other
therapeutic areas,
this may not be such a unique or novel
concept because I think other areas have done a
lot more pre-marketing work in terms of dose
optimization. There are less pressures that we talked about in
terms of speed and getting
good enough therapies out to
patients
in an expeditious manner. And just for reference, we've
talked a lot about these publications and guidance
documents. The FDA Oncology Center of Excellence has really
been
very active and proactive in guiding all other
stakeholders on
how to roll this out.
So some of the key guiding principles of Project Optimus,
as we've heard
with targeted agents and immune agents, we have all these new
modalities. The MTD and DLT, while
important,
is less relevant as compared to cytotoxic chemotherapy,
and you have to focus on the optimal biologic dose.
You have to focus on long-term tolerability and safety,
given that many cancers now have turned into
somewhat chronic diseases. We're giving these therapies now for
years on end, so we have to rethink
what are some of the long-term considerations in terms of
tolerability and safety. And of course, we have to use the
totality of evidence to maximize the benefit risk
profile.So just to go
back in time to a few cases,
as Dr. Shah said, there was a lot of
antecedent history
that led to Project Optimus. I just selected a few
case studies to
help see how this project
was informed and what led to all these workshops and stakeholder
meetings, and what the drive was to get more of a
focus on optimization in the pre-marketing setting.
So one of the agents is the OG
ADC gemtuzumab
ozogamicin, or Mylotarg.
It was first approved in 2000,
and it received an accelerated approval in CD33 positive AML.
The initial dose was nine milligrams per meter squared.
It was withdrawn in 2010 due to safety
issues, including hepatotoxicity, veno-occlusive
disease, and sinusoidal obstruction, myelosuppression.
And due to extensive work by the sponsor
in collaboration with cooperative groups, it actually got
reapproved in 2017
at a lower fractionated dose, three milligrams per meter
squared, in combination
with cytotoxic chemotherapy, which improved the therapeutic
index.
Next, we have Dr. Zhen Zhu in the house.
I think he worked on extensively with cabazitaxel.
This was a drug,
a microtubule inhibitor, second generation, that initially was
approved in CRPC and prostate cancer in 2010.
And actually, there was a post-marketing requirement
to study a lower dose. The initial dose
was 25 milligrams per meter square.
There was a lot of
bone marrow toxicity. And actually, it took a really
large, over 1,000-patient non-inferiority
study,
which actually is in the cabazitaxel label, to show that the
lower dose is
non-inferior in terms of survival with less
requirements for growth factor support, less myelotoxicity.
So the idea is,
can we do this earlier and make earlier decisions so we don't
have to run these large, expensive
Phase 4 studies to revise the dose?
Another example that I was involved with when I was at the agency
was a drug, a next generation ALK inhibitor called ceritinib.
It ran the three-minute mile. It was a really rapid
accelerator approval program
in 2014.
But
because of the expeditious nature,
the dose was approved at a very high dose
fasted.
And
with review of the drug, it became clear that a lower dose
with food was just as tolerable. So there was a post-marketing study.
This was updated in the ceritinib label that a lower
dose with food has a better benefit risk profile, less
GI toxicity,
and
led to the approval. And then finally, the first generation
G12C inhibitor, sotorasib, had extensive
discussion at an ODAC with an accelerated approval,
also in non-small cell lung cancer.
Also has been approved in colorectal cancer with a Code Break
300. And actually,
the dose of 960 versus 240, the
960 dose in CRC was taxane was positive, 240 not.
So this is straight from the FDA label, where actually the higher
dose, although
is the approved dose in the product label.
So we did a little bit of work to look at
dose-related PMR/PMCs across
modalities in the pre-Optimus era.
And it looked like it was fairly stable, the number
of
PMR/PMCs. A key metric
going forward is will this
number actually go down with Project Optimus?
Hopefully, it will because there'll be more work done in the pre-marketing
setting.
We also looked at
some of the PMR/PMCs did not lead to relevant
label changes. Some do. So
always sitting back from when I was at FDA, you have to
be very judicious and
deliberative in thinking about when to
mandate a post-marketing study for dose.
And it's important to always look back to see which experience
led to label changes versus not.
So we talked a lot about randomization versus
backfill, adaptive design strategies, and industry has
really, and academia have embraced this and have moved
away from the 3+3 design to more Bayesian type of
approaches.
There's active backfills at Stage
1b. At Stage 2, at dose finding,
typically there is randomization, two to
three dose levels. I'll show you in a subsequent slide where three dose
levels might actually make more sense than two,
depending on the specific case.
Leading into efficacy studies, either single arm or
randomized, you could also run your Phase 3 confirmatory
study with two doses
and then drop a dose with an interim analysis.
So we've seen a lot more of that as well in the Optimus
era.So this is a conceptual framework
devised by Azra Hussain
on three different doses, and you can
see
dose one is still on the linear
slope of the efficacy curve. So
that's sub-optimal efficacy. Dose
two is really where you want to be. You're at that J
curve,
where the efficacy is starting to plateau out,
but the safety is still increasing.
And then dose number three is what we would have done in the
pre-OPTIMIS era with cytotoxic chemotherapy, where you're at your
MTD, you're already plateaued in terms of efficacy,
but safety would still continue
and toxicity pace.
So really, when you're looking at D1, D2, D3,
you would really need to look at potentially three dose levels to
find that D2, because if you're only comparing D3 to
D2, that could lead to misleading results, or D2 to
D1 as well.
You're not really rounding out your
toxicity and safety assessments.
These are just some examples of non-randomized
comparisons, some cautionary tales.
Not to say that--
Obviously,
when
all things being equal, randomization is always preferred, but one can argue if
you're looking at small cohorts, 20 patients per cohort,
how much does randomization give you versus backfill?
That's an argument or debate we could have.
But it is important to know that there can be
differences and time-dependent differences, both in terms
of safety and efficacy,
when looking at backfill. So in this example with
brentuximab, if you look at the curve
on the left,
peripheral neuropathy occurs late.
So you could be misled if you were looking at two
different doses comparing peripheral neuropathy.
The higher dose, actually, the peripheral neuropathy looks
reduced. However, you're not taking time as
a confounding variable. So analytic approaches to account for
exposure matching, longitudinal models, milestone analysis
may help mitigate for the differential follow-up.
Similarly, in CLL,
for example, with BTK inhibitors,
if you backfill and there's differences in time
with two different doses from an efficacy perspective, if you have
really delayed response rates, you can be misled
when you're assessing efficacy between two doses.
So just a cautionary tale
when you're looking at non-randomized approaches.
So as we've heard today, multiple factors and
the totality of evidence is critical for optimized
dose evaluation. You have to look at efficacy, exposure
response modeling, safety, tolerability,
immunogenicity. You have to factor in lines of treatment,
novel metrics like growth rate and tumor size changes,
maybe radiomics. Look at tumor types,
covariates, other PD metrics. We heard a lot
about patient-reported outcomes,
POP PK, dose schedule, and target expression.
So it really takes a village. It takes a whole multidisciplinary
team to inform dose. It's not going to be you plug
in certain metrics in a spreadsheet and voilà, you get your
optimized dose. You really have to look at the entire picture.
So some opportunities and challenges for Project OPTIMIS going
forward. Opportunities, we've seen more innovative
adaptive trial designs early in development.
We've seen more reliance on modeling and simulation.
So our PK modelers are very happy
with Project OPTIMIS.
We've seen the development of novel PD markers.
There's an opportunity to adapt Phase 3 and drop a dose after an interim
analysis. You could argue, who gets to make that
decision? How do we operationalize? That's a discussion we could have.
And we want to get the dose right the first time.
We want to cut down on the number of PMCs and PMRs.
Some of the challenges, as we talked about, oncology is a little different from
other TAs. There's speed, there's rapidly changing
standard of care. There's low tolerance.
No one wants to leave efficacy on the table for
patients. There's uncertainty on when to extrapolate
across tumor types and combination partners.
We need more clarity on when it's optimal to randomize versus
backfill. And there's a gap in validation or qualification
of novel PD biomarkers, including ctDNA,
radiomics, biometrics, and PRO.
But ultimately, we need recommended doses that best
accommodates most of the intended patient population.
We can deal with some of it in the labeling with special populations, dose
reductions. Clinicians over time know how to use these drugs.
That's why they're called oncologists. That's what they get paid to do.
Sponsor ultimately needs latitude to proceed at risk
after gaining agency alignment. So with that, I
thank you for your attention, and we can move on to the Q&A.
And yeah, if you have questions, please come to the mic because we have
people streaming online as well.
Hi, Evan Rosenthal from Vanderbilt University.
Great session. Thank you very much.
I'm curious where
the PK/PD fits into this
optimization and in the trial. So how do you incorporate
plasma levels and those sort of biologic
markers of drug activity?
Anyone want to take that? I'm not really sure who that's for because it's a broad
question.
So, thanks for the question. So, I guess I'll
start at the end of your question with things like PD
markers. And so, in terms of
how we think about data needed for dosage optimization
decisions versus what would be needed for a marketing approval, I
think there's a lot of opportunity to look at kind of novel markers of
drug activity as part of the decision making for
dosage optimization, especially things that can be measured on a shorter
timeframe or more frequently than more traditional markers of
activity like response rate. That being said, I think my talk
tried to emphasize that there isn't just one piece of information that
should supersede all other pieces of data available to make your
decisions about dosing. But I think that dosage optimization
space is one space where there is opportunity to look at kind of
novel markers of activity, so novel PD
markers. I don't know if anyone else wants to comment.
Any thoughts?
Is this on? Yes.
Obviously, as you have heard before, instead of having two or six
patients per dose level, we might have 20 patients per dose level
because of the backfill or the expansion.
So this gives us more data, but you're right, there is no threshold
to say if this outcome is below a value, then
we declare the dose as not optimal.
But the field is looking for such answers so that it's a
binary decision for each dose.
I can make one other comment too about the
PK aspect of your question. So of course, it's very important in dose
escalation to understand what is happening to exposure
as dose increases. Something my clinical pharmacology colleagues
often point out is that to have kind of really,
really good exposure-response relationship information, one of
the limitations with our historical approach to dosage selection has
been all of your exposure-response information is, or most of it is,
coming from just one dose that patients have been exposed to.
And by having more exposure data available for more patients
at more doses, it allows a much richer characterization of
those relationships than might have occurred if you had six
patients at two or three different doses and then 100 patients receiving
one dose.
You can also include it. I think the PD information can be
used both in the dose escalation and the dose optimization stage.
In the dose escalation stage, once you identify the doses
that are tolerable in that set, like once
you've selected, then you want to ensure that there's some dose-exposure
relationship too.
So if there's no PD and there's no activity,
that might be something that you want to know early on.
So that might inform that decision as well.
And of course, in the dose optimization stage, it would be good to have the
dose-exposure relationship for the doses that you have selected to go
on.
Yeah.
Thanks to the panel for a great talk. My name is Bhargava Kandala from Merck.
This question is for Dr. Shah around Project
Optimus. So as sponsors, we do see some
variability across different divisions within the
FDA in terms of how some of the intricacies of Project
Optimus is applied, not at a high level, the MTD versus the
dose with the best risk benefit. And as sponsors, we do
acknowledge that some sort of flexibility is needed, I think based on the
disease, what options are available to the patients, et cetera.
But I'm wondering, are there any initiatives within the Project
Optimus team or the quantitative medicine where you look at over the sphere of five
years of approved drugs and you think about how Project Optimus was
applied, and is there any plans to share that with the public to say, "Hey, this
was our initial guidance. Now, this is the evidence of how it was applied across
these different drugs,"
and any rationales or maybe
on some drugs why
things were a little more flexible versus not? So just a question to Dr. Shah.
Thank you very much for the question.
So, I think as you saw in my talk, I shared some recent examples of
dosage optimization, but I think that's just the beginning of us trying to
share what we've learned with this initiative over the past five, now
almost six years.
So that's one aspect in terms of socializing what we've
learned. In terms of consistency, yes, we
recognize that this is challenging.
Dosage optimization was something that we were also learning as we
were developing the guidance. That being said, the review teams are doing their
best to provide advice that is specific to that therapeutic
area, and so there might be differences because we're trying to also
be not one size fits all, but this is what's going on in the therapeutic
landscape of breast cancer compared to GI malignancies, and this is
what's the context of available therapies and this biomarker and this
disease and things like that. So there might be differences in the advice, but it's
not because of lack of consistency, but because there are different
considerations and different indications.
But absolutely, we do have plans to kind of reflect on the
program and share what we've learned and where we think things need to go
also.
Thank you, doctor.
Dr. K. Liu.
Thank you so much. It's a great session.
I have a question
for Dr. Shah and maybe the whole panel.
In your slide, 10, I believe, the kind of
generic pathway
that built in the randomized groups.
For small molecules targeted at
heart, it's kind of relatively easy to do that.
For the newer kind of molecules, for example, TCEs
or T-cell activators, and not alone, but
cell therapies. I wonder what
the
general guidance on that part, because you may not
have
that classic clean form
to predict different doses, even though you do
different groups in the randomized session.
I can start. I think my other colleagues may have other comments.
So I think your question is about some of the newer
biologic products, and I understand
there might be more that needs to be done in terms of
understanding step-up dosing and things like that, things that are not really
part of the dosing regimen development for a small molecule
kinase inhibitor. One of the examples I shared,
tarlatamab, was actually for a bispecific T-cell engager, and
you can see that it wasn't two different doses that were being compared,
but it was really two different regimens with the same actually initial dose for
the step-up and then different doses for the
full dose for the regimen. So that is one example.
I do understand what you're saying, though, in terms of complexity of the dosing
regimens. Definitely something that we need to think more about.
Okay.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Yeah. Thanks. Okay, up next.
Kirill Sabta from Children's Mercy. Great talk from everyone.
I guess just a general question for the panel.
In considering the totality of evidence, as you mentioned, there's a lot of
different factors to consider in Project Optimus.
How do you see it interacting in the combination therapy space, especially given
all the logistical, clinical, statistical considerations that do now
have to be added when you do consider a combination therapy, such as where do you
see the field heading under these guidelines?
Yeah. Great question. It becomes more and more
complex once you're combining multiple agents.
I think
if you can establish monotherapy activity
and establish the monotherapy optimized dose,
oftentimes, I think
as long as there's not a great deal of overlapping
toxicity between the combination partners, you may be able
to
go right into
registrational or confirmatory type of
experiments. You may not need to
repeat randomization or backfill
with each combination partner. I don't know if others on the panel have thoughts.
Right. This is a great question since we didn't cover it in the talks.
So when we combine the two drugs, we no longer are in the
setting where we have one dimension as we go up, we have
some expectations. Now we have a grid because it's two-dimensional.
But we can still divide the grid in three areas where there is
some safety and activity, where it's completely unacceptable, and
where it's too low. And there are statistical methods, again, they rely on
modeling and not heavy assumptions because they update the
model in the Bayesian setting, and they override the initial
assumptions of how this relationship is expected to
be versus
it is based on the observed data. So we can use these model-based
approaches in combination therapies to find the
maximum tolerated dose or a contour, multiple levels,
and then decide to expand to a bigger sample size if
we want to address
optimization.
But the methodology is out there and can be used. There is also software.
I'll just add that stepping back, I think the most important thing
for combinations is thinking about what is the relationship between
the drugs, just in terms of big principles.
Is there PK interaction between these drugs?
Are there overlapping toxicities? What are those toxicities?
I think we all understand that it would be impossible to do every single
iteration of different doses of the combination.
That would be exhaustive. We might not learn enough to make that
effort worthwhile, and time and patience are very
limited. But if there are areas where both drugs cause
diarrhea, for example, something like that, very important to try and
optimize the dosing of the combination.
One additional limitation, as
my colleague alluded to, if there's good monotherapy dosage optimization, it
does make the combination a lot easier.
One thing we're contending with now is that if a newer drug is being put in
combination with an older drug that was poorly optimized at
its dosage, and particularly if they have overlapping toxicities, that's
a particular challenge for the combination, and probably some work would need to
be done to characterize the dosing better.
Thank you.
Can I actually follow up, just take prerogative on that last
comment. If you're in a metastatic non-curable
setting and the standard of care, like you said, hasn't been
optimized fully, is it okay to go with a
lower dose of the standard of care?
If you have a good handle on the experimental therapy, then
otherwise.
Yeah. So I think we get this question a lot, and yes, with justification,
even if there's one recommended dosage and labeling and you're developing a
combination and you want to look at a lower dose than the one that's
recommended in labeling, I think we would be accepting of that, and we have been
accepting of that historically. One example is
capecitabine for breast cancer. Probably many in the audience is familiar
with. Actually, through FDA's Project Renewal, we updated the
labeling for that product to have the dose in the
label for breast cancer reflect what was already occurring in the clinic and
is a better tolerated dose than what had been
recommended in the FDA labeling for a long time.
But even before that update was made, we were open to combination
regimens using lower doses of capecitabine.
Please.
Jack Wu from Takeda. A great panel here.
Two quick question. One is follow-up on the previous question there is
particularly for novel/novel combination.
How do you think about addressing the contribution of components
in light of dose optimization? Which dose you're going to use to
address that? Second question is particularly thinking
about IO engine that has a broad
potentials in different indications.
How do you leverage the data you generate from other indication to
accelerate your dose optimizations in new indications?
Great questions. Actually, very similar questions online.
So do we want to tackle
contribution of components and novel/novel
combinations,
extrapolating cross tumor types?
I think there are a couple papers on those finding
designs where you actually include the information on attribution of the
toxicity. However, that can be quite complex with novel/novel
agents, right? Usually when we're designing new
combinations, one thing that I usually tell clinicians is to make sure that they
know about the attribution, if there's any information on
that. And to know, for example, what the adverse event rates
are for each particular dose level.
When it's novel/novel, the information can come from actually earlier trials that
are actually the monotherapies might be pretty, just had the phase
one, for example. And that information, if it's in-house with you, I think
that information can be modeled. You can try to leverage that
information that you have in-house,
and
usually we'll request it from pharma if they have that information available.
I think any data for a novel/novel agent is information that you
want to use in the design stage.
And with IO, it's a little different, right? The profile is different.
So if there is any long-term
information, it's always very helpful as well.
So not just like the first cycle or first two cycles.
If there's any information that you have about long-term toxicity,
can be useful in the dose selection decisions.
Yeah. Mira, maybe do you want to comment on the
requirement to optimize dosing across different tumor
types? I guess there are some examples like in HER2,
trastuzumab had different dose recommendations based on tumor type, but
what's the overall philosophy there?
Sorry. So
I'll answer that question and then I'll go back to the earlier portion of your
question. I was writing down some notes.
So yeah, absolutely. For subsequent indications,
you do not have to repeat dosage optimization.
So that means you don't have to do randomized dosage evaluation
in every single indication, especially every single solid tumor, for example,
indication that you want to evaluate.
There does need to be rationale for the dose that you are putting into the
new indication, and there might be
situations where, for example, ribociclib has two different
doses in the metastatic setting and the early setting.
Those are two very different settings, and so it's important to
think about what is different in terms of the patient population, what's
different in terms of how they will be on this drug, how long they
will be potentially taking this drug, and use that to
inform whether further work needs to be
done or whether a different dose, even using information you've already
collected, could be leveraged to justify a different dose for
that
next indication. In terms of your question for novel/novel
drugs and contribution of components, I think it's a very
complicated development program or perhaps more
complicated than a monotherapy, we can all agree.
So very important to plan early. I was going to
refer to a few FDA guidance documents actually that might be helpful in terms
of thinking about the big principles.
One is something that's been around for a long time, but it's the co-development of
two novel drugs guidance. I think it's been around for over
a decade at this point, perhaps even a little bit longer.
The other more recent guidance document is on
contribution of effects and establishing the contribution of effects, and I
think just very important to understand that you'll need to address
that early as you're building your development program.
Also, I think you were alluding to
how do you show contribution if you're also still figuring out your
dose. I think in that dosage optimization period,
typically those are doses that are anticipated to be active, right?
Those are not necessarily either one of those doses or one of those three
doses you're studying because you think one of them could become the
recommended dose in labeling. And so you can show among
these different doses that are active, maybe it won't be the full
activity if you end up going with a higher dose or
you might be figuring out is the higher dose more active than the lower dose.
But you can still use that to understand both of these drugs have
activity and then look at the nuances further from there.
Cool. Thanks.
Yeah. Hi, I'm Bob Kerbel from the University of Toronto and
the Sunnybrook Health Sciences Center in that
city. The presentation's not
surprisingly all concentrated, in the main,
on targeted drugs, targeted biologics,
immunotherapies, and not so much on cytotoxic
chemotherapy.
But there have been a group of us for about the last 20, 25 years who've
been investigating the idea of, in a sense,
dose optimization of cytotoxic chemotherapy
drugs. And here I'm referring to the idea of
low dose continuous, sometimes called metronomic chemotherapy.
And since chemotherapy is still the backbone of a lot
of cancer therapies
and is used in a chronic form in adjuvant and maintenance
treatment settings,
what I'm wondering about is whether some of the principles you have talked about so
eloquently,
some of the considerations, clinical trial designs, and so forth,
should be applied to conventional cytotoxic
chemotherapy drugs as well. Where they're not really used as
cytotoxics necessarily. They become
essentially the equivalent of a biologic agent.
I tried my best not to be technical, but I have to be technical in this
very good question. So of course, we have the ethics, right, guiding us.
So if the curve is steep or we expect it to be steep or
not flat, right? Meaning the higher the dose, the more the
cytotoxicity, then we absolutely cannot be
backfilling, right? Because backfilling means we are giving dose that is
too low, subtherapeutic, and we can absolutely not
overdose. So we studied that a lot, right?
So we have models and techniques to dose escalate in that
area. But where it gets complicated is that we are
not actually in the PK/PD field, where we're trying
to characterize the dose response curve.
We're not trying to characterize it everywhere.
We are trying to be as accurate as possible at the
right dose, which I know it's very difficult to
conceptualize, but we are trying to find the location of the right
dose with as few patients as possible. That's our goal.
And how do we do that? By eliminating low levels or high
levels. In the
cytotoxic setting, it's easier than when the curve is
flat, because when the curve is flat, we need more patients to
characterize that curve and decide where to
allocate patients.
Last word.
I was going to say, yeah, in the longer version of my talk, I
acknowledge that many had recognized, even for cytotoxic
therapies before we had these newer drugs, that dosage optimization
could be very, very important. I think
throughout the session, we've talked about examples of cytotoxics actually
that did benefit from dosage optimization.
So cabazitaxel, capecitabine, and then of course, antibody drug
conjugates do share a lot of properties with cytotoxic agents in terms of their
dose response relationships. And those have illustrated, starting with the
OG, great capacity for dosage optimization.
So I certainly think the principles are applicable to cytotoxics.
Thanks.
Well, thank you so much. Unfortunately, we're out of time.
We had such a great
dialogue and apologize for those who submitted online, but
really thank you for your attention. Thank you to the speakers.